well when I was in front of Labor Party
members last year fighting to be the
deputy leader of the party I said that I
would work with whoever the party
leaders the party elected as leader and
I've done that for the last nine months
the best of my ability but I think now
I've resigned because it just isn't
working I think that one of the first
things that a labor leader has to do is
be able to communicate to the country
and our voters and yet a few days before
the EU referendum over 50% of them
didn't know what our position was and we
were the only party that was United in
campaigning for remain and with the
general election likely to be looming as
you've heard from what the Conservatives
are doing accelerating their leadership
campaign with a new prime minister who I
think will seek a new mandate quickly we
need to have someone at the helm of the
labour party that can speak out for the
communities who are going to suffer most
from any recession that happens as a
result of brexit I do think he's feeling
right now well look I I Jeremy is a
honest and decent man and I know that he
has done his best and I think he's
chartered a new way forward for the
Labor Party but I just don't think that
he can communicate or lead the party in
these tumultuously times I think he must
be feeling wretched I think a lot of us
are feeling wretched I'm certainly
feeling wretched but I think the party
is bigger than any one person we exist
to represent communities that have had
opportunities taken off them that are
poorer and harder hit as well as lead
our country into a social democratic
space where there are more opportunities
and if you can't do the
then I think you have to acknowledge
that and step aside and let somebody
else do that joy the Labour Party is a
party about uniting people isn't it and
you know you've not just stabbed him in
the back as a group you've stabbed him
in the front you've stabbed him any way
you can
I haven't stabbed him at all I tried to
see him yesterday I texted him and asked
to have a face-to-face meeting with him
yesterday I got absolutely no response
for 24 hours I finally had to chase
around and get him to phone me this
isn't the first time that there's a
dysfunction around the way that things
are done or communication is bad and it
in the times were entering into in these
dangerous times from our country I just
don't think that that is adequate it
just won't do and it has to change what
about the grassroots backlash because he
still has a lot of support look I
understand that but I gave a pledge to
our party members that I would serve I
have done so to the best of my ability
for the last few months and I've
concluded after a great deal of
agonizing and examination that it's not
in the best interest that this continues
especially with the political challenges
that lie ahead for our country and the
communities that we went into Parliament
to represent and so I've done where I've
done today with a very heavy heart mmm I
suppose some might say that now is the
time that the Labour Party should have
been united I mean look at what's
happening with the government there
literally flailing around not knowing
which direction to turn and yet you're
not offering them a credible opposition
well I think today if Jeremy does what I
hope he will do and realise is that he
should go with dignity after setting us
off on a new course and helping us think
very carefully differently about the
future that should
his legacy and I think he needs to
realize that it's not about him this
isn't about him it's about the country
and about steering the labor family
through these times so that we can serve
our constituents in our country properly
by having an effective opposition a
credible opposition I think today
unfortunately is the first step towards
bringing that about if he stands again
he's more than likely going to be your
leader again listening well look i would
say - jeremy please understand that you
can't continue as leader if you have no
support within Parliament amongst your
colleagues the fact is he cap well I
think that the Labour Party is bigger
than the personal interests of anyone
but I'll rather than him I mean he is in
step with the grassroots it's it's his
shadow cabinet that is not we have to
communicate with the wider electorate
with labour voters and with the country
as a whole equation - every years they
don't know no he clearly isn't I've been
on a lot of doorsteps up and down the
country in the last period we had a very
simple position in the
that we were for remain he did not
manage to communicate that position to
the country as a whole in that
referendum campaign was lackluster and
it wasn't clear that labor voters was a
I mean a lot of labour voters decided to
vote out a lot of labour voters were
looking to the Labour Party for a proper
indication of what we should do and
Jeremy didn't succeed in communicating
so there's fault that we've now left the
European Union no of course not I think
that we have to cope with the aftermath
though and that is causing huge
difficulties and we know that our
communities in the north
places where often Labour MPs represent
or have already being the hardest hit by
the cuts that the Conservative
government have inflicted on them since
2010 that they're now facing an even
bigger head and we came into politics to
defend them and after agonizing I've
come to the conclusion that Jeremy isn't
the person that can do that I've said
that to him and I've asked him to
consider resigning and I hope that he
will do so ok will you stand I think
that today is about trying to restore
credibility to the labour party I don't
think today is about specularity or
shoot for the audience and if people are
looking for guidance so they're looking
for people who if it's not going to be
Jeremy Corbyn who is it gonna be I think
that are you interested I think that
what today is about is persuading Jeremy
though with dignity with a good legacy
of changing the way that the party works
and how its organized and if that
happens then Tom Watson will be the
interim leader and then there can be a
discussion about any kind of future
leadership contests but you've got to
get that process in order today is about
saying to Jeremy with all respect please
please put the interests of the Labour
Party first and resign it sounded like a
Labour version of Boris Johnson he would
never say whether he was going to stand
or not are you going to start think
that's the biggest insult as a
profession of Boris Johnson I've
agonized over the weekend I've done what
I've done and it's now up to Jeremy okay
do you I'm gonna ask you at the final
time
if you were asked to stand would you and
I'm saying that I today is not the day
for having that discussion I think today
is a day for deep reflection for Jeremy
our leader and I hope that he considers
what everybody has said and realizes
that it's in the best interest of our
party the communities we represent in
the country that we preserve we don't
watch this guy news if he's watching
right now what would you say to him well
Jeremy I talked to you earlier today I
express my admiration
you've done and I hope that you realize
that you will be remembered with great
fondness as a good leader of the party
who charted a different direction
but you must remember that the party is
bigger than you and I hope that you'll
realize you can't continue without the
support of the problems and no offense
intended
thank you very much enjoy yeah thank you
very much thanks